In this video we will see together what is
the purpose of training a tokenizer, what
are the key steps to follow and what is the
easiest way to do it.
You will ask yourself the question "Should
I train a new tokenizer?"
when you plan to train a new model from scratch.
A trained tokenizer would not be suitable
for your corpus if your corpus is in a different
language, uses new characters such as accents
or upper cased letters, has a specific vocabulary,
for example medical or legal, or uses a different
style, a language from another century for
instance.
For example, if I take the tokenizer trained
for the bert-base-uncased model and ignore
its normalization step then we can see that
the tokenization operation on the English
sentence "here is a sentence adapted to our
tokenizer" produces a rather satisfactory
list of tokens in the sense that this sentence
of 8 words is tokenized into 9 tokens.
On the other hand if we use this same tokenizer
on a sentence in Bengali, we see that either
a word is divided into many sub tokens or
that the tokenizer does not know one of the
unicode characters and returns only an unknown
token.
The fact that a "common" word is split into
many tokens can be problematic because language
models can only handle a sequence of tokens
of limited length.
A tokenizer that excessively splits your initial
text may even impact the performance of your
model.
Unknown tokens are also problematic because
the model will not be able to extract any
information from the "unknown" part of the
text.
In this other example, we can see that the
tokenizer replaces words containing characters
with accents and capital letters with unknown
tokens.
Finally, if we use again this tokenizer to
tokenize medical vocabulary we see again that
a single word is divided into many sub tokens:
4 for "paracetamol" and "pharyngitis".
Most of the tokenizers used by the current
state of the art language models need to be
trained on a corpus that is similar to the
one used to pre-train the language model.
This training consists in learning rules to
divide the text into tokens and the way to
learn these rules and use them depends on
the chosen tokenizer model.
Thus, to train a new tokenizer it is first
necessary to build a training corpus composed
of raw texts.
Then, you have to choose an architecture for
your tokenizer.
Here there are two options: the simplest is
to reuse the same architecture as the one
of a tokenizer used by another model already
trained,otherwise it is also possible to completely
design your tokenizer but it requires more
experience and attention.
Once the architecture is chosen, one can thus
train this tokenizer on your constituted corpus.
Finally, the last thing that you need to do
is to save the learned rules to be able to
use this tokenizer which is now ready to be
used.
Let's take an example: let's say you want
to train a GPT-2 model on Python code.
Even if the python code is in English this
type of text is very specific and deserves
a tokenizer trained on it - to convince you
of this we will see at the end the difference
produced on an example.
For that we are going to use the method "train_new_from_iterator"
that all the fast tokenizers of the library
have and thus in particular GPT2TokenizerFast.
This is the simplest method in our case to
have a tokenizer adapted to python code.
Remember, the first step is to gather a training
corpus.
We will use a subpart of the CodeSearchNet
dataset containing only python functions from
open source libraries on Github.
It's good timing, this dataset is known by
the datasets library and we can load it in
two lines of code.
Then, as the "train_new_from_iterator" method
expects a iterator of lists of texts we create
the "get_training_corpus" function which will
return an iterator.
Now that we have our iterator on our python
functions corpus, we can load the gpt-2 tokenizer
architecture.
Here "old_tokenizer" is not adapted to our
corpus but we only need one more line to train
it on our new corpus.
An argument that is common to most of the
tokenization algorithms used at the moment
is the size of the vocabulary, we choose here
the value 52 thousand.
Finally, once the training is finished, we
just have to save our new tokenizer locally
or send it to the hub to be able to reuse
it very easily afterwards.
Finally, let's see together on an example
if it was useful to re-train a tokenizer similar
to gpt2 one.
With the original tokenizer of GPT-2 we see
that all spaces are isolated and the method
name "randn" relatively common in python code
is split in 2.
With our new tokenizer, single and double
indentations have been learned and the method
"randn" is tokenized into 1 token.
And with that, you now know how to train your
very own tokenizers!